die App skyscanner ermöglicht es jeden
Tag von überall auf der Welt die
günstigsten Flüge zu buchen zusammen mit
einem Kollegen habe ich mich fünf Tage
auf die Reise gemacht mit dem Ziel jeden
Tag ein neues Land zu sehen viel Spaß
mit der zweiten Folge jeden Tag
günstigster Flug irgendwo halt dann hin
tschüss was bisher
geschah falls ihr die erste Folge noch
nicht gesehen habt schaut ihr am besten
zuerst wir sind auf jeden Fall in Köln
gestartet und erstmal ging es mit einem
Flug nach sad in Kroatien eine ziemlich
coole Kleinstadt am Meer an der
kroatischen Adria dort sind wir dann mit
einem Boot in die Altstadt gefahren ich
habe hier auch schon die nächsten Flüge
gebucht wir haben uns dort ein bisschen
umgeschaut waren insgesamt ja einen Tag
da einen Abend haben abends noch die
Altstadt angeschaut dort war alles aber
eher ruhiger wollten dann abends noch in
einen Club oder eine Bar die meisten
hatten zu also die Saison ist wirklich
vorbei am nächsten Morgen hatten wir
dann diesen schönen Ausblick von unserem
Hotel aus oder unserem Apartment waren
dann erstmal einkaufen und noch schön
Schwimmen im Meer das war wirklich noch
sehr angenehm und hat uns wirklich Spaß
gemacht dann gab es noch kurz was zu
essen und abends ging es dann weiter mit
dem nächsten Flug nach Krakau in Polen
in Polen war ich einmal auch für ein
Youtube Video wir haben uns dann abends
noch auf den Weg in die Stadt gemacht
bisschen schade dass wir erst so spät
abends da waren und in Krakau war
einiges los ja ähnlich wie in Danzig
damals irgendwie ziemlich viel scam auch
aber war trotzdem lustiger Abend am
nächsten Morgen gab es noch Frühstück
und eine Massage und dann sind wir
weitergefahren ach ja falls euch diese
Videos gefallen würde ich mich sehr über
ein kostenloses Abo freuen und damit
herzlich Willkommen zu jeden Tag den
günstigsten flugbchen vier Tage
hintereinander part 2 wir sind schon
seit zwei Tagen unterwegs aktuell
befinden uns noch in Krakau haben wir
gerade ausgecheckt und jetzt geht es
weiter wenn ihr es gesehen habt im
ersten Part ansonsten schaut i euch auf
jeden Fall zuerst mal an wir fliegen
nach Griechenland tessaloniki
tessaloniki wir haben auf jeden Fall
schon einiges erlebt in den letzten
Tagen und ich bin mal gespannt wie es
jetzt noch weitergeht erstmal
tessaloniki das habe ich auch im letzten
Video schon gebucht und von dort aus
wird es dann morgen noch irgendwo
weiterhin hingehen wir warten gerade auf
unser btaxi zum Flughafen hier in Krakau
und dann fliegen wir nach tessaloniki
ich wünsche euch viel Spaß beim video
ich glaube es wird wieder sehr sehr cool
und sehr sehr lustig und ja let's go
also ich weiß auch nicht der steht schon
seit 5 Minuten da oben an der Kreuzung
was ich mich gerade frage meinst du ih
hier kann man wählen oder ist das ein
Musiker oder ein komedien meinst du ih
hier kann man wählen oder ist das
Musiker oder ein
komedielsk ich den schon dass Politiker
ist
politikerich deutch se
politiers der SCH eigentlich macht einen
guten Eindruck bel hat aber schon auch
so ein
knealenscherf oder ja oder hättest du
gern also der hätte gestern Nacht auch
hier bei dem Club da vorne als
türsteller stehen mit dem hätte ich
nicht gern Streit aber ist ja auch gut
ich glaube das bräucht mal in
Deutschland auch mal bisschen
mer wir gehen ih schon mal
entgegener
yes also ich hatte in letzter Zeit
wirklich schon oft so driver wo ich mir
dachte aber bei dem ist gerade wirklich
sehr kritisch uns wäre gerade fast so
ein Taxi von links volle Möhre hier
reingaust aber wir sind noch am Leben
wohlfühl Taxi geht anders also der hatte
auf jeden Fall irgendwas intus be dem
geht's nicht gut nee muss man ja auch
wohl mal ein bisschen natürlich geht sow
nicht aber vielleicht gibt's ja auch
Gründe für wenn er irgendwie zu viel
arbeitet oder so das war echt gerade
eine sehr riskante Taxifahrt hier mit
uns beiden das war sehr heik
ja hier oben stehtst do schon up in
Lounge
te du musst hier durch durch den Beauty
free so hier Business
[Musik]
Lounge also an sich haben wir hier eine
wirklich große Lounge H geht sogar noch
runter und dann setz wir uns unten da
bequem hin also hier ist wirklich für
jeden was dabei können wir gleich
weitermcheno gestern aufgehört haben
mein lieber schli also das ist glaub ich
die größteority loue die ich bis jetzt
gesehen habe nicht schlecht für mich
gibt jetzt erst ein leckeres
gemüsesüppchen mit ein bisschen Brot und
eine Pepsi zerro also die Gemüsesuppe
ist wirklich richtig strong richtig
lecker meine Mama macht die auch immer
zu Hause aber die kann fast mithalten
und ich kann ja nicht Polen verlassen
ohne wenigstens ein T getrunken zu
haben lecker auf nach tessaloniki aber
gut dass du so ein langes Ladekabel
dabei hast praktisch ne praktisch ja
unser Flug hat leider leicht Verspätung
aber jetzt haben wir Boarding ich glaube
der hat es vergessen die R Mitarbeiterin
meinte gerade meine Tasche ist zu groß
und jetzt mussten wir einfach ein paar
Sachen rauspacken zeig mal jetzt hat's
geklappt aber ich dachte das kostet
wieder 25 € extra ich Rei halt immer mit
dem gleichen Rucksack und das war
eigentlich noch nie ein Problem außer
einmal na ja so Flug Nummer 3 haben wir
auch ich muss sagen ich habe
ehrlicherweise überhaupt keinen Bock
aber was willst du machen platzgenommen
haben wir eine Reihe für uns immer
möglich spät einchecken und dann könnt
ihr schauen welche Reihen noch frei sind
e hier ist eine Hitze drin in diesem
Flugzeug es ist unfassbar und ich habe
unter meinem Pulli leider nichts runter
ich sterbe
[Musik]
wirklich oh ist aber irgendwie total
kalt Alter ich dachte hier wär es wärmer
so Leute angekommen
tessaloniki aber echt also maximal 18°
würde ich sagen nur Leute hier ist auch
schon eine Stunde später als in wo waren
wir davor noch mal Krakau in Krakau eine
Stunde später das heißt wir haben schon
21:50 Uhr in krakehaus ist erst 20:50
Uhr aber na ja was halt wirklich ein
bisschen schade ist wir kommen echt
immer erst so richtig spät abends an
aber man kann halt nichts machen diese
günstigen Flüge sind irgendwie aktuell
alle abends so kurz noch Hotel gebucht
das habe ich irgendwie vergessen wir
haben jetzt irgend so ein Apartment für
79 € grey Studio ja schauen wir mal das
heißt ab ins Taxi und nach tessaloniki
[Musik]
h geh ganz gut los aber nur
Barbezahlung
wobei in Deutschland gibt's auch noch
super viele taags wo man Hal wirklich
nur B Seen kann aber Deutschland ist
auch komplett
[Musik]
zurückgeblben okay wir sind auf jeden
Fall jetzt hier bei unserer Unterkunft
glaube ich zumindest das muss hier
irgendwo sein also hier heißt das zwar
anders als hier aber Kamera ist leider
leer wir sind jetzt hier in dem Aufzug
so ungefähr halben Quadratmeter und
müssen jetzt mit Pincodes in unser
Zimmer auf Etage 8 ich hoffe das klappt
weil wir haben richtig Hunger ey Leute
wir gehen jetzt richtig nice hier
griechisch essen dazu noch ein richtig
schönes griechisches alphab biier kannst
du doch wirklich nichts sagen oder
kannst nicht me kannst du nicht meckern
nachdem wir schon viermal unseren
Pincode eingegeben
haben das ist eigentlich echt ein nices
Zimmer muss ich sagen Dusche wow
Toilette das bin ich und guck mal hier
guck dir mal den großen Balkon
wenn man jetztch aufs Meer gucken kann
weil wir sind ja eentlich direkt am
Meer wow
Alter
nice welcome tessaloniki Yamas Bo Leute
geile Stadt guck mal raus so wir haben
erstm direkt das nächste griechische
Restaurant aufgesucht gute Bewertung
online einf so auf das muss man in
griechenlandehmen spät unsere Mahlzeiten
sind irgendwie immer super unregelmäßig
und wir müssen erstmal jetzt wieder
bisschen auf Power kommen freue mich
jetzt schon auf den Hauptgang was machen
wir heute noch wir stürzen uns mal ins
Nightlife hier in tessaloniki schauen
wir mal was da so kommt schauen wir mal
ja also so ungefähr ein Kilometer von
hier wo wir jetzt gerade sind ist so der
Hotspot für Bars und alles Mögliche was
man halt so nachts machen kann und das
schauen wir uns gleich mal an wo es dann
morgen weiter hin geht weiß ich noch gar
nicht und ich weiß auch nicht ob ich das
heute noch ermitteln kann oder ob ich
morgen früh aufwache und wir dann
irgendwie schauen es muss ja ein anderes
Land sein das ist ganz wichtig also
nicht irgendwie ein anderer Ort oder
eine andere Stadt eine andere Insel in
Griechenland sondern wirklich ein
anderes Land schauen wir mal
boah so das ist unser Hauptgang wir
haben beide Kebab mit ja also sieht halt
anders aus als in Deutschland Kebab ne
ich bin mal gespannt ich bin eigentlich
nicht so der Fleischfan der so wirklich
ich esse eigentlich nicht so gerne so
viel Fleisch aber wird schon schmecken
so wir haben jetzt hier ein local beer
da steht zwar fix drauf aber es ist
Mythos also ich muss ja überall auch ein
Local Bier probieren das ist ja immer
ganz wichtig
lecker das liegt aber daran weil ich das
schon kenne das haben wir nämlich als
wir auf kretabahn immer getrunken
mythosbier alpab biier was gibt's noch
ach so ja fix Hellers auch ganz lecker
mehr kenne ich nicht aber die sind alle
gut also in Griechenland können die
sowas wir machen uns jetzt auf dem Weg
nach da hinten da vorne ist nämlich
glaube ich so eher Hotspot sind jetzt
aber hier direkt schon am Meer
also ist halt leider wieder dunkel nervt
mich auch ein bisschen dass immer wenn
wir ankommen ist schon dunkel ist und
ich die Orte nicht im Hellen zeigen kann
sondern halt erst morgen so aber
meistens geht dann auch der nächste Flug
schon wieder Teufelskreis so wir sind
jetzt hier im ausg Viertel oder Party
viiertel keine Ahnung was auch immer
sollen wir hier mal reingehen oder
weiter
geradeaus ja würde ich auch sag das do
schon mal ganz interessante
[Musik]
Musik n Palace Alter wo sind wir hier
also wir sind jetzt auf soem Platz und
wirklich rings um uns herum sind überall
nur Clubs und irgendwelche Musik und so
und ich habe auch im Internet gesehen in
tessaloniki soll es wohl richtig abgehen
nur man muss auch sagen die Leute sehen
hier alle total schick aus und wir sind
so semi also ja mal gucken ob wir
reinkommen wir versuchen auf jeden Fall
jetzt hier in diesem Club zu kommen kper
schon ich könnte mir vorstellen D dass
wir nicht
reinkommen also so sieht das hier drinen
aus ist nicht verkehrt aber ja so wir
die Stimmung kommt auch nicht auf
[Musik]
und damit Leute einen wunderschönen
guten Morgen aus tessaloniki in
Griechenland ja wir sind gerade
aufgestanden haben schon auf unserer
schönen Dachterrasse hier einen Espresso
getrunken ich muss wirklich sagen das
merke ich jedes Mal in Griechenland
gibt's richtig leckeren Kaffee egal wo
ihr seid der Kaffee schmeckt eigentlich
immer ich habe echt Bock auf den Tag die
Aussicht im Hellen hier ist auch
ziemlich geil klar wir sind hier mit in
der Stadt und um uns herum sind überall
nur ja Häuser und ziemlich hohe Häuser 1
2 3 4 5 5 6 7 8 ne Etagen wir sind hier
auf der achten Etage bei uns das meerr
ist gar nicht weit von hier einmal da
durch und dann ist man schon am Strand
das werden wir uns jetzt gleich mal
anschauen aber ich muss auch sagen dass
ich jetzt mal eben checken muss wie die
weitere Reise verläuft weil wir haben
jetzt schon 11 Uhr und wir müssen heute
auf jeden Fall noch irgendwie in ein
anderes Land kommen ich hoffe das klappt
aber wird schon irgendwie also hole ich
mal mein Handy und wir checken das mal
aus weil morgen ist dann eigentlich
unsere Rundreise auch abgeschlossen und
wir müssen zurück nach Deutschland dann
ist auch schon Sonntag aber schau jetzt
erstmal wo es weiterhingeht also hier
kann wirklich aushalten ist zwar ein
bisschen laut aber wir haben Hal einfach
26° so ich bin auf skyscanner und hier
geben wir ein entdecke günstige
Reiseziele für Samstag den 14 okay ganz
oben haben wir Griechenland 55 € ach so
ja okay das ist ja gleiches Land das
zählt schon mal nicht weil wenn ihr den
ersten Part gesehen habt es ist die
Aufgabe jeden Tag in ein neues Land zu
reisen aber iraclio wä auch geil das ist
die Hauptstadt von Kreta 53 € na ja geht
leider nicht dann geht's weiter Rumänien
nach Bukarest 67 € okay das ist schon
mal Quatsch der fl du kostet nicht malhr
67 € sondern über 119 manchmal ist das
alles nicht ganz aktuell wobei ich auch
sagen muss die Flüge sind alle ziemlich
teuer und dann haben wir hier noch
Vereinigtes Königreich London 71 € okay
ist auf jeden Fall günstiger 71 € um 21
Uhr nach London mit Jet2 habe ich ja
noch nie gehört ja dann wird's
wahrscheinlich der weil das wird der
günstigste sein wir werden hier keinen
günstigeren haben Alter die Flüge sind
also für jeden Tag der günstigste
flugvide ist das auf jeden Fall extrem
teuer oder war hier noch einer der
günstiger war nee das ist auch viel zu
teuer Leute nächstes Ziel wird sein
London welcher Flughafen ist es London
stanad glaube ich oder ne stad oder
Stanford stad okay ich buche und auf
geht's so jetzt gibt's erstmal hier was
zu essen ich habe mir hier so ein
griechischen Joghurt bestellt mit
Granola und so wenn man schon mal in
Griechenland ist kann man das ja machen
und leckeren Cappuccino wir jetzt schon
aufgegessen und dann geh gleich auf
jeden Fall erstmal zum Strand also wenn
ich mir in Deutschland sowas zusammen mi
ist es deutlich schlechter ne ist schon
lecker mega geil okay Leute wir haben
auf jeden Fall zu Ende gefrühstückt und
machen uns jetzt mal auf den Weg zum
Strand ich bin mal gespannt wie wie es
da im Hellen aussieht weil hier hast du
wirklich überall nur hohe Häuser um dich
rum aber irgendwie hat es was finde den
flir hier ganz nice wir könnten uns
natürlich auch so ein paar
sehensfürdigkeiten angucken so
griechische was gibt's den da also hier
gibt's bestimmt einiges aber ich bin
jetzt auch nicht so der
Sehenswürdigkeiten Fan wisst ihr ja wir
müssen auf jeden Fall jetzt einfach nur
geradeaus und dann kommt da der Strand
ah da sind wir doch schon hier ist das
Meer falls man es erkennen kann ja gut
Leute also wir sind auch gestern schon
hier an der promenale lang gestppt ein
Strand ist hier gar nicht die Strände
sind wohl weiter in die Richtung also
zum Flughafen wieder hin ey der Verkehr
hier ist wirklich Katastrophe ne wie in
Thailand ich glaube man muss auch
einfach mal gehen wow hier sind auf
jeden Fall einige Fische
[Musik]
drin ja was machen wir
jetzt rein oder okay Leute wir sind auf
jeden Fall jetzt im Taxi und fahren in
Richtung Flughafen unser Flug ist ja
erst heute Abend um 21 Uhr aber wir
wollten noch ein bisschen da zum Strand
gehen und hier hat man überall halt nur
diese Promenade und und dachte mir ja
komm jetzt die letzten Sonnenstrahlen
hier im Sommer weil hier ist ja noch ein
bisschen warm kann man
mitnehmen also mit Roller auf die
Autobahn und dann ohne Helm hast du das
gerade
gesehen das Taxi war irgendwie ganz
schön eng ne Leute das sieht doch super
aus schön mit Blick aufs Meer hätte ich
jetzt auch nicht gedacht dass ich sowas
noch mal sehe zumindest jetzt nicht auf
dieser Reise aber geil GU mal ist doch
hier wie auf keta
oder schon sehr ähnlich ich glaub das
hier ist auf jeden Fall so ein SC Wasser
wenn du das jetzt anrührst kostet
wahrscheinlich 6 € wo wir es gar nicht
bestellt haben weißt du aber haben wir
nicht gerade hingestellt ich habe's aber
ja nicht bestellt so noch 45 Minuten ist
unser Essen auch mal da wirklich das
also das hat so lange gedauert ich
glaube dein Club Sandwich ist
wahrscheinlich schon kalt oder nachdem
der da hinten 24 mal rauf und runter
gelaufen ist um zu ermitteln wir dann
das Club Sandwich gerade aber eine
Pommes probiere ich mal schön
Cross wo ist eigentlich dein Getränk
aber
Steig aber ich hoffe dein Clubsandwich
schmeckt okay mittlerweile in
tessaloniki wieder am Flughafen jetzt
gleich geht's nach London wir haben
jetzt noch ein bisschen aufentthilt das
heißt es geht wieder in die nächste
Lounge das macht irgendwie voll Spaß
wenn man so jeden Tag sich so eine
andere angucken kann mal gucken ob die
heute gut ist da oben steht CIP Lounges
the Lounge für die die immer fragen wenn
man in eine Lounge möchte braucht man
ein priority Pass den kann man sich
besorgen wenn man die MX Platin sich
kauft die kostet 60 € im Monat ich habe
das auch gemacht könnt ihr euch gerne
über meinen Link holen und dann kommt
ihr in die laounge rein das ist
zumindest ein Weg um in die meisten
Lounges zu kommen ach krass da kommt man
vielleicht sogar mit der Visa und
Mastercard rein das weiß ich gar nicht
ja gestern war besser ne aber wir wollen
gar nicht meckern hier gibt's auch Webs
und
[Musik]
Getränke so die erste Lounge haben wir
jetzt verlassen jetzt gehen wir mal hier
in die nächste Lounge Sky
Express so was sagst du zuur anderen
Lounge auf J Fall sieht besser aus die
ist ein bisschen geräumiger
ne okay Leute wir sind jetzt hier am
Gate hinter uns ist jetzt der Flieger
nach landondon ist natürlich jetzt schon
wieder ein bisschen später aber na ja
interessant ist wir haben jetzt hier
20:42 Uhr sind in Griechenland und in
London ist es gerade erst 1842 das heißt
zwei Stunden vorher okay let's go ich
habe Bock freust Dich denn schon auf
London freue mich auf Lon immer dran
denken wenn es na Großbritannien gehen
soll Reisepass oh sonst kommt ihr
nämlich nicht mit aber jetzt wird nur
noch Englisch gesprochen bitte okay ich
weiß gar nicht mit welchem das heißt
irgendwie Jet 2 habe ich noch nie gehört
vorher das ist jetzt unsere Flug
Fluggesellschaft hier gibt's jetzt zwei
Flügel zur Auswahl links und rechts ich
glaube links einfach mal auf gut Glück
[Musik]
[Applaus]
rein also bei jedem
klug diger diger was soll ich machen
meine
ganze
irgendwie haben die auch gar nicht
gefragt ob wir das nicht mal hochklappen
wollen weißt so Leute angekommen in
London London e es ist so kalt ne wir
sind gerade einfach nur 7° wir sind von
21° zu 7° gejettet und ich habe einfach
noch hier meine kurze Hose an auf jeden
Fall sind wir hier in sted wir fahren
jetzt gleich mit dem Zug denke ich mal
nach London rein weil es ist übelst weit
also ST ist 40 km außerhalb oder so bis
gleich so wir holen uns jetzt noch
schnell was zu essen weil das Problem
ist ich habe jetzt schon uber bestellt
wir haben schon so spät und wir wollen
heute auch noch was von Landon sehen und
wir sind so weit außerhalb ne das ist
echt krass wir könnten auch den stad
Express nehmen wir sind hier in London
stad aber der kommt erst wieder einer
halben Stunde und wir wollen halt jetzt
schnellst möglich dahin so jetzt gibt
erst noch paar Chili shees Nuggets die
können wir dann im uber Essen ne ich
merke jetzt schon Landon ist teuer
verdammt teuer gehen wir jetzt nach
Landon wie geht
landen heute geht Party in landen hallo
sorry illegal i don't know sorry Leute
wir sind auf jeden Fall jetzt hier im
Taxi der Taxifahrer ist irgendwie total
stinkig auf uns weil wir in einer
falschen Stelle eingestiegen sind und
der macht uns die ganze Zeit fertig aber
wir verstehen nicht alles boah Alter ey
der Flughafen stet ist ja arschweit
außerhalb wir sind jetzt erst um keine
Ahnung wir haben eigentlich fast schon
wieder den nächsten Tag wir sind jetzt
auf jeden Fall hier im Hotel und gehen
jetzt erstmal zur Rezeption man muss
auch dazu sagen das war auf jeden Fall
das teuerste Hotel mit Abstand von allen
280 € es gab kein günstigeres heute das
muss man sich mal vorstellen ey Leute
ich kann nicht me wirklich es ist so
hart anstrengend wir sehen jetzt seit
vier Tagen nonstop unterwegs jeden Tag
irgendwo anders es ist jetzt gerade 0:30
Uhr in London und in tessaloniki ist es
jetzt schon 2:30 Uhr weil wir halt
wieder Zeit zurück hatten wir sind jetzt
hier im teuersten Hotel der Stadt
gefühlt es gab nichts günstiges 20 € für
eine Nacht diger das sieht nicht nach F
Sterne aus jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
ich wirklich so also ich bin echt
bisschen fertig muss ich ganz ehrlich
sagenil zimmertechnisch sieht das ja gut
aus ne den krako hät du sonst immer für
50 € bekommen jetzt haben wir das
Fünffache bezahlt landondon ist
expensive ist das eine Frage ob man das
aufmchen kann oh oh ohne Fenster ohne
Fenster ja super Fenster gibt's zwar
aber geht nicht auf das liebe ich doch
ja ich meine für 280 € Prod kannst du
nicht meckern ne und die Frage aller
Fragen ist jetzt eigentlich was machen
wir noch wir sind wir haben eine Nacht
einen Abend in London wir können jetzt
nicht direkt schlafenen Triss weil
morgen geht's zurück du weißt es du
musst arbeiten ich muss Montag ja Video
schneiden was machen wir jetzt okay der
Plan ist jetzt folgender ich stehe hier
alleine draußen das Ding ist nämlich
dass Tristan ziemlich ko ist von den
letzten Tagen ich auch aber ich wollte
jetzt einfach noch mal hier raus weil
ich muss ja auch irgendwas noch machen
kann nicht einfach hier nach landondon
fliegen und nichts machen ah my uber
driver hey
Alex yes al Alex Roxy Club yes hier
haben wir zumindest schon mal diese
typischen London British Autos war hier
noch zwei Harry Potter Busse und da
vorne ist sogar Harry Potter Museum ey
das sieht übelst nice aus oder nehme
mich mit ich muss nach Hogwarts so und
hier müssten jetzt gleich irgendwo meine
Freunde sein ohne Witz Leute ich würde
mich auch viel mehr jetzt schon im Bett
sehen aber einer meiner besten Freunde
ist auch hier und der wohnt nicht mehr
in Deutschland sondern in Dublin und
deswegen dachte ich mir komm ich gehe
auf jeden Fall jetzt hier noch vorbei
aber eigentlich bin ich so ko wirklich
[Applaus]
[Musik]
bin so wir sind jetzt hier noch im Taxi
das ist f hi freut mich alles fit ja das
ist
Julian und einem Chris alles fit alles
super was machen wir jetzt noch schlafen
gehen ich bin müde zeig mal dein RAV was
ist das für eine Mannschaft die
Baltimore
Ravens Fußball fball se Quatsch
interessiert mich gar nicht für na ja
auf jeden Fall gehe ich jetzt
ausschlafen ich bin total müde ey also
die letzten Tage stecken mir richtig
hart in den Knochen morgen früh geht's
noch frühstücken und dann war's das
glaube ich auch mit meinem Reiseprojekt
aber wir schauen mal wir sitzen hier in
so einem typischen London Taxi ne
ziemlich beschlagen hier wir sind alle
so heiß gute
Nacht ja die Aussicht hier ist nicht so
berauschend Leute und damit schönen
guten Morgen aus London wir schauen uns
jetzt noch ein bisschen hier die Stadt
an gehen noch was frühstücken wobei gut
ich war auch schon mal in London und
aber fürs Video natürlich versuche ich
trot noch was einzufangen und heute um
14:45 Uhr geht unser Flug von London
Heathrow das ist ganz gut der Flughafen
ist sich so weit außerhalb zurück nach
Köln und dann ist unsere 1 Z 3 ja
eigentlich sogar fünftägige Reise
beendet und ich muss auch sagen ich bin
echt recht froh es ist wirklich
schweinekalt ne also ich glaube wir
haben höchstens 8° ich habe gar keine
Jacke mit nur hier diesen Pulli und da
drunter noch so ein kleinen Pulli bin
mal gespannt ob es in Deutschland auch
so kalt ist habe ich jetzt noch nicht
nachgeschaut man merkt auf jeden Fall
dass der Sommer vorbei ist ne das sieht
doch schon mal ziemlich britisch aus
hier Bri aus wir treffen uns jetzt noch
mal mit meinen Kollegen von gestern die
auch schon kurz im Taxi kenelernt habt
und gehen in ein English Breakfast also
dies typische breakfast breakfast halt
nel wobei die können ja nicht so gut ein
[Musik]
Cappuccino wie wär soll wir hier nicht
noch ein
paar tolle Klamotten mitnehmen hier
gibt's ja einiges Mensch wo kommt das
ganze Zeug den
Weg und hier soll Stück geben W
[Musik]
Shad Christian erzähl mal wo geht er
denn jetzt heute hin weil ich sehe ihr
hab beide so ein footballtck an und hier
ist he
foballspiel wer spielt wer spielt datim
Ravens gegen Titans also ich habe da ja
gar keine Ahnung von und du bist von
seahwah ach das sind amerikanische Teams
ne und die spielen auch manchmal in
München oder letztes Jahr war auch
einmal in München ne wieder ein aber ich
weiß nicht W
spielt ja okay ja geil dann lass es mal
krachen ne ich sehe schon hier sieht
doch gut
[Musik]
aus okay wir sind mittlerweile wieder in
Heathrow am Flughafen und es geht jetzt
nach 5 Tagen Reise wieder zurück nach
Deutschland ich muss sagen auf der einen
Seite bin ichich froh natürlich auch ein
bisschen schade wir haben ziemlich viel
erlebt in den letzten Tagen hat auf
jeden Fall richtig viel Spaß gemacht
aber ich bin jetzt auch einfach echt
platt Christan ich hoffe dir hat's
gefallen ja gut guter Tripp oder aber
reicht jetzt auch reicht jetzt auch ne
leute lasst da mal oben da abonniert den
Kanal für weitere reisevideos und wir
sehen uns denke ich in paar Tagen schon
wieder weil
ja ich weiß jetzt schon dass ich nächste
Woche wieder weg bin und wo es dahinht
seht ihr dann haut rein Ciao so nicht
genau ein